ich bin der Erhard Griess ich bin
Militär Luftfahrzeugtechnik am System
Eurofighter auf der Flightline intec
[Musik]
hinter mir steht jetzt unser
Schmuckstück der Eurofighter im gigalog
was war die Idee dahinter natürlich die
österreichische Flagge sollt Österreich
repräsentieren die Alpen am Tail hinten
sollen die Landschaft Österreichs
repräsentieren und die Tigerstreifen bzw
der Tiger hat bei uns ein den Sinn da
durch das wirtiger Member sind also bei
einer teilweise ist eben der Tiger als
Motiv gewählt worden warum ist er weiß
wir haben ihn deswegen weiß gemacht weil
er einfach optisch mit dem rot-weiß-rot
schwarz am besten zu mir kommt
alle sonderlackierten tigermaschinen
zugleich in der
[Musik]